kann man menschenleben gegeneinander
abwägen ist es so komplex zu sagen ich
meine klar wenn man eine zahl hat wenn
man sagt ich könnte einen töten anstatt
fünf oder wenn ich den titel eben 5
welches recht haben wir überhaupt diesen
gedanken zu haben
ich meine wir dürfen diesen gedanken
haben weil die gedanken frei sind aber
ich glaube solange ich nicht in so eine
situation komme werde ich mich nicht mit
diesem gedanken befassen im sinne von
dass ich nicht mich also dass ich keine
entscheidung treffen werde
wie es dann in der wenn ich sagen ich
komme so eine situation die muss ja
nicht mit zug und und schiene und brücke
die kann ja 1000 verschiedenen
möglichkeiten entstehen dann hängt es
davon ab sind leute persönlich die du
persönlich ganz davon betroffen sind
sind sind leute die du nicht magst davon
betroffen dass dann vielleicht noch ein
schwieriger sagen wir fünf neonazis sind
auf der schiene und was würdest du
machen es noch mal eine ganz andere
frage aber ja ich würde sagen ich wage
nicht
ich wage nicht eine entscheidung zu
treffen solange ich nicht selber in
diese situation kommen